i don't think that it's this big self
sacrificing move on his part
i think that rick has a kick-ass life
where he lives with his best friend at a
bar
that he owns
where he gets to gamble and smoke all
night
inside i think rick has the best life
that he could possibly have
and that he cons this woman
hello and today we are
hey hi there hello hey man today we're
going to be talking about the most
misunderstood movie moments in history
it's based on an article we have up on
looper.com and this is a tough one
because you always want to pick
something that is in fact misunderstood
by people and that you actually know
something about
um
it's tough because you know for
something to be misunderstood you have
to kind of say like this is
misunderstood and i a very smart person
understood it right and as i looked at
this list and thought about it i was
like man i must
not know very much um but i did my best
uh but before we get to the thing that i
wanted to talk about i wanted to ask
nina what was one of the most
misunderstood movie moments that you
were gonna pick
well brian um as far as the list on here
on looper.com there's one i wanted to
give a quick mention to which is 500
days of summer which is a movie that i
quite like
and uh
yeah i feel like a lot of people came
away from that movie being like summer
sucks she is mean to tom and i'm like uh
he doesn't listen to her at all
ever and
the director and everybody involved with
the movie have all been like yeah we
meant him to be kind of a jerk who
doesn't listen to her she is very clear
with him about what she wants and
doesn't want and she's fine tom is the
problem
and i mean that of all times
just to be clear yeah so we're on the
same page so no but like joseph
gordon-levitt's character is the problem
but
perfect um yeah joseph gordon-levitt's
character and he's even i think the
actors even admitted it was was the
issue not her so that's that's really
that's a series of misunderstood moments
as is my actual pick
brian you told me before this chat that
you thought you knew what i picked and
i'm going to tell you now and i'm so
excited to see if you're right
my pick
is josie and the fussy cats i knew it
was going to be josie and the pussycat
okay so when that movie came out
it flopped nobody like critics didn't
like it they were all wrong everybody
was wrong that movie is is great
and
i didn't want to spoil
my surprise by wearing my super yucky
shirt but you've all seen me in that
many times and
basically when it came out everybody was
like oh like it's pr all product
placement it's so stupid
placement right like why are they
advertising the stuff yeah they didn't
get paid for any of that stuff they just
did it to prove the point and so
everyone seeing that movie missed the
whole point which is the movie is about
like how capitalism is bad and
industries exist to exploit teenagers
and
like by the way please hit like and
subscribe
so that we can keep our jobs but no um
what we would be so clutch if you did
it would be so jerking if you clicked
like absolutely
that's one of the ones they make up in
dozing the pussycats
um so yeah i i think that movie is
really smart and really funny has a
great comedic cast i mean if you put
allen coming in parker posey in the same
movie i'm gonna watch it a hundred times
i think anyone with any sense would do
the same missy pyle's also there
crushing it like rosie rosario dawson
tara reed rachel lee cook all perfect
so yeah i i don't
i don't think i need to explain to you
guys why this movie is misunderstood but
yet people completely missed that this
that the product placement was super on
purpose and very pointed and instead
they criticized it for specifically that
and thankfully years later it's become
like a cult classic and it's gotten its
due and people have finally figured out
like oh that's why that's the point
it's wild to me that anyone might have
missed a lot of people did like it's
very blatant like what they're doing
it's pretty obvious right like
yeah
i love that movie i will champion it
forever and i'm glad that it has
gained new life thanks to the internet
and people who
people like me and us who are like yeah
this movie is good actually just watch
it again give it a shot
internet's always doing good stuff
yeah
so yeah good my the other pic so i
thought of that one and and as i was
thinking about it i was like oh that's
the one nina probably picked so let me
come up with a backup yeah that was the
only thank you thank you um the only
other one i had was the movie
now now again is this misunderstood
this is a tough one right like it's it's
not on our list and we'll get to the
list um before the end of the video but
um this is a movie that i know i've
talked to at least a couple of people
who were like i saw it i thought it was
kind of dumb at the end it was so
cliched
and my response was always like that's
the point and this movie is called
adaptation have you guys seen
adaptations yeah i love that movie
so like the first half of the movie is
charlie kaufman struggling played
amazingly by nicholas cage nicholas
twice well charlie kaufman and his twins
yeah and then so then the other half of
the movie is
written by donald kaufman his alter ego
his twin the the dumb screenwriter who
does the all the things
that in the beginning charlie says he
doesn't want to do literally it's like
it's like boxes getting checked
and that's that's the point of the movie
that's the joke of the movie that is the
idea here that yes it's it's hitting all
these cliches yes the drugs the drug
subplot the uh
marital infidelity subplot the
the people learning life lessons as they
die sub flat you know like our great uh
plot point or
i don't know it's just one of those
movies that when i've talked to a few
people who who have tried it they've
been like yeah i don't know it didn't
work for me it's like well the reason it
didn't work is because maybe it's
because you're not smart that's why no
yeah but i'm just that that was one of
the ones that kind of that struck me as
like this is one that might actually be
misunderstood where like basically you
know
none of the stuff in the movie is
actually
it's real like
in the world of the story yes all these
all these things did happen in the world
of the story yes charlie kaufman has a
twin brother named donald who's who's
really dumb um
but the whole movie itself is
like you're you're what it's it's a it's
a very meta movie you're watching the
screenplay get written and you're
watching it turn from art house
movie about nothing kind of you know
screwing around
failed adaptation to a different kind of
failed adaptation which is taking
everything amping it up to 11 making it
as hollywood as possible doing all the
things that you didn't want to do in the
first place and still making it work
somehow all by the end so well and i
feel like a movie that came out recently
just to piggyback off of that really
quickly that i felt like a lot of people
really fundamentally misunderstood uh
with that i love is promising young
woman which came out uh in 2020
and i have if okay then i'm not going to
spoil that movie in its entirety but
um
basically a lot of people were like
no i'm not going to spoil it because you
guys haven't seen that would be mean
well then no spoilers
no uh basically there was a lot of
chatter about like is the ending
satisfying and you know it's a movie
about about you know men taking
advantage of women and my argument is
like i don't think it's supposed to be i
think that's i think you're wildly
missing by the point by asking is this a
satisfying ending because i think that
what the writer director emerald uh
fanel was trying to do was be like there
are no satisfying outcomes in situations
like these or they rarely are and so
like
yeah i think similar to adaptation it's
like it knows what it's doing and people
are like i didn't like the ending
because it's it's a cliche or it's not
satisfying it's like well then you're
missing the point if that's what you're
mad about you're missing the point of
what came before
i gotta check that movie out it's really
hard to talk about this movie without
spoiling it so this is not helpful it's
like almost impossible so
let's let's move along
sorry tom what about you what is it what
is a misunderstood movie moment that you
wanted to talk about
this one might just come down to my
personal opinion but uh but it
uh casablanca you ever hear of a movie
called casablanca
once or twice yeah okay it came out like
around the time you were graduating high
school brian it's eight yeah that's
right
back in my day they didn't like uh they
didn't like titles uh that weren't in
english so they just called it white
house
oh brian
moving on
we'll probably cut that don't worry go
on no no no no i think we should frame
that that was
that's going on the fridge the end of
casablanca i i have been under the
impression for years that
nobody understands it except me and i'm
gonna make my case right now at the very
end
this is one of my favorite movies so i
am really excited to see where you go
with this one of my favorite movies too
uh they had a bunch of levels but at the
at the very end uh when rick sends the
love of his life away on on an airplane
that he could have gotten onto it but he
he's like no go with your husband
get out of here
i don't think that it's a big self
sacrificing move on his part
i think that rick has a kick-ass life
where he lives with his best friend at a
bar
that he owns
where he gets to gamble and smoke all
night inside
i think rick has the best life that he
could possibly have
and that he cons this woman
into a very dangerous trip back to
trying to get back to america right like
that's that's where they're trying to
fly off though this is the darkest
vision of splunk i've ever heard and i
love it it's a matter of opinion my
friend but i think that uh
i think that rick has some i think he
has his life figured out
and nobody gives him credit for that
the other interpretation of casablanca
if you've never watched it this way it's
remarkable my dad clued me in on it a
few years ago and it makes it impossible
to watch it any other way if you just
assume that every other male character
in the movie is in love with rick
totally different movie like
100 like it holds
up it's like it's a remarkable story
still but like it just just very
different like peter laurie doing the
whole oh you despise me don't you all
right if i ever thought about you i'm
gonna cut the tension between those two
with a knife seriously like those big
wet frog eyes that that guy
is just remarkable
great that's my pig
well there are a few items here on this
list on looper.com that i wanted to
discuss as well uh one is the ending of
total recall
oh yeah definitely
you say it's definitely a dream
absolutely and
uh paul verhoeven has also come out and
said
yes this is definitely a dream which i
can't kind of think is a bummer but i
guess you know i think you can i think
this is one of those movies that you
could
i think it's stronger if it's ambiguous
in my opinion i don't necessarily think
it's misunderstanding it it's like you
say it's definitely a dream why do you
say it's definitely a dream tom
well it's we talk about this a lot the
setup and payoff like they they set
everything up in the beginning of the
story like uh when they're when they're
when they're loading the uh the program
in
uh for him to go like they they list
everything that he's gonna do they list
everything that's gonna happen and they
even explain like and then there'll be
like a bright flash when we lobotomize
you or whatever it was and uh and all of
that stuff happened and like the movie
ends with him at the end of the story
watching a bright flash of light
i love paul verhoeven man i don't mind
saying it i think i think he's terrific
i think he's
actually if we're talking about under uh
or misunderstood
movies like most of what he's done
i think probably falls into the category
roboco yeah like all starship troopers
and all the movies that people starship
troopers is on this list that's the next
one on this list and that's when i fully
admit
you know i saw starship troopers in
theaters when that came out i was in
high school
i was the high school principal yes
because i'm so old um
there's the joke
i was gonna let it go but i'm proud of
you
but i saw it and again like that one for
me it was like something about this
isn't quite quite sitting right like
there's it's this movie feels weird and
i don't understand
why it feels so strange and it doesn't
it's not working i don't understand i
don't like this movie it makes me feel
bad
um and then years later you know you
start to realize that oh
this was a satire the whole time it's
satirizing everything it's saying to you
is a joke it's trying to show you that
that you know fascism and militarism and
violence and all this stuff this is
actually really really bad it
dehumanizes people it turns people into
these you know
this
garbage this garbage that just makes the
world worse and you're participating in
it by not thinking critically about
anything that's happening and you know
again to a 16 year old it's like
you're either you're either here for it
because there's a lot of violence and
it's fun and exciting or you're put off
by it like so many people were so this
movie was a flop at the time
um
maybe it wasn't a flop but it was
definitely critically
not not well received and only years
later has that kind of been
revised and then we were talking a
little bit about robocop just a second
ago that's one
where i know i saw bits and pieces of it
when i was a kid and then years and
years and years later i finally
watched it like from start to finish and
i was like oh my god this movie is
incredible like just you know again the
layers of satire of
again it's all about kind of glorifying
violence it's about corporate interest
dehumanizing people literally
dehumanizing and then the fight to be
more human and it's a movie called
robocop and it's got a a cyborg police
officer shooting a bad guy in the crotch
like yep amazing you know so it's got
everything you could possibly want truly
um
another one on here that's good that i
remember
uh was a.i
it's fine
uh but basically at the very end
uh i'll just kind of share this have do
you guys know about the ending of that
yeah of that film i do now because i
just read about it on looper.com yeah i
mean you see like at the end he it
everybody at the time was just like it's
so dumb there's aliens show up at the
end like that was like everybody was
like why does this movie end with aliens
like what's what's the deal with this
movie ai and the answer is like they're
not they're not aliens they're they're
robots in the future that's kind of
they evolve um yeah there's a few on
here there's a few good ones on here
it's pretty good it's hard to come up
with a good one though the fight club
one is pretty good
yeah in that like people were like
yeah like people were like oh we should
be like that and fincher was like wow
way to miss the point entirely yeah well
i mean
i don't know to be fair to be fair to
the people who missed the point
fincher sure did make that violence look
cool yeah he did very true yeah who
among us did who what my man looked at
that movie and was like i don't want to
be brad pitt that seems terrible
right exactly so i mean it's yeah
with my shirt off
yeah i think it's a really well made
movie i think it's a really
i i think overall it's a good movie but
i also think that it's it's probably not
that hard to miss the point because
it's so
i mean like being a cool macho guy who
looks like brad pitt who who tries to
enact a counter-revolution against
corporations and all these things is
like like yeah why wouldn't you want to
do that why i mean it does glorify and
violence in a lot of ways ultimately it
is still the bad thing
um and you do have to kind of use your
brain a bit to kind of get over
this the message that no actually the
brad pitt character is the bad guy no
actually
beating people up for no good reason is
bad like these are bad things
but um
yeah i don't know it's uh you're right
though he does make it look extremely
cool
the same thing happened when i watched
the social network i went i started my
own social network it didn't work out
and then i lost all my friends when i
got sued for millions of dollars when i
saw devil wears prada i left the theater
and i was like her friends sucked that
job was awesome and my mom was like i
think you maybe missed the point
that
i was like why were they so mean to her
[Laughter]
that's not the point of that movie
either
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe
[Music]